hello ladies and gentlemen I'm gray and
on John we're going to be doing a beauty
in the beast review Oh Oh some nail
don't know my face is supposed to mimic
me exactly I don't know all right so we
saw Beauty and the Beast 3d 3d oh my god
that snow was like actually there you
know what man I was impressed by 3d in
this movie and I'm usually not impressed
do you like everything hey like man I
like this movie I did like this I did
III didn't feel it's perfect and I
didn't feel it
I wasn't swept away by it I did find a
lot of really awesome things about it
though yeah there's a lot to admire
about this movie even if it's not
sweeping you off your feet from
beginning to end
yeah like there are definitely moments
where it is yeah well the movie starts
off they give us a prologue it's not in
the cartoon they give us this prologue
that really shows us you know how the
beast became the Beast and why and
everything so should be and I didn't
care for it I didn't like it I actually
thought that it would have been cooler
if the first time we see the beast is
when Belle's father played by Kevin
Kline shows up at the castle Ellie it's
all mysterious and we're wondering
what's going I mean if you've seen the
cartoon you know but but as a first-time
viewer I would feel like I'm in this
character shoes I don't mind I wonder if
they maybe tack that on to it like the
inevitable children would not be as
scared when he first shows up because I
was seeing that dude that's kind of
scary but yeah yeah especially when
you're seeing this all in real life and
I'm not cartoonish yeah they're like oh
wow that he could really just show a
human being but that's what I wanted
like it would have been scarier yeah
yeah I don't like I already know the
whole thing now is a prologue area
because I haven't seen the cartoon and
probably over a decade I knew it well
enough to like know I like you to have a
backstory does like one of the few
things they added that I didn't care for
one thing they had for an enjoyment
thing like I wasn't hot on it but I did
I do appreciate that as sort of like
lead into some
they're doing it's like you know it ties
them together like all the storybooks
you know here's a little narrated piece
oh yeah the first one had how to narrate
a piece as well but did wasn't that yeah
I wouldn't play like that I think Emma
Watson does a really good job I mean she
she's so beautiful I'm so glad she had
this giant movie after Harry Potter I
like him once in general and I liked her
and Harry Potter there's a thing where
like I don't get like [ __ ] yeah I'm a
Watson like a lot of people do and so
this was a nice surprise for me because
you know it's been a while since I've
seen one of her movies and she did charm
me a whole lot in in this yeah she does
play Belle in a really natural kind of
way you know
Oh toto she's able to carry off those
big sort of sweeping emotions she's able
to make you sort of enchanted by her I
don't know how to sing and I don't even
know how to like tell truly when
someone's like not good at singing or
something
like if someone sounds nice I mean it
sound nice and then like professional
singers I'd be like they're not that
good like how everyone reacted at wal
online the difference with this movie is
you got a lot of actors you could really
sing like hit Broadway musical notes you
know yeah I never Watson it was the
first time I watched the movies like oh
this is what like a film actors scene
lesson sounds like a now it's good but
it's not on the caliber of the other
singing performances in this film I
think yeah and this is the first time I
think I really like consciously noticed
that in a movie where I can actually
bring it out we like yeah I feel like
most everybody overpowered her singing
performance rope like she sings all the
songs nicely but her voice isn't as
strong I guess as a lot of the others
like she's a fine singer but you know
she's not a Broadway singer yes what I
will say though one thing that she did
exceptionally well is the same thing I
feel about the the cast members in law
all that was they still kept the emotion
there while they were saying yes while
she's not hitting that like the notes of
how a lot of the cast members might be
able to hit them or the original cartoon
I felt her emotion though and it was
very much present and like the way she
heard her expressions and everything it
was like she's still given a good
performance though she's doing a really
good job it doesn't look actually just
focus on the scene yeah focus on the
meaning of the words which I really
appreciated and I felt like that can
make up or whatever you feel she's
lacking in because I don't think it's
like distracting that she's on the same
par but it is kind of noticeable yeah /
yeah I noticed it periodically because
some some four songs are better than
others to it like when she gets songs
that are a little more suited to her
voice I don't remember them being
numerous but there are a couple times
where you like oh yeah that was yeah
Luke Evans though I think is great in
the film yeah I thought he did a
terrific job I thought he was hilarious
I felt he brought him a three
dimensional performance to it I felt he
was actually layered yeah I thought he
was the right size because because I
know a lot of people aren't into its
portrayal because you know he's
different from the spirit of the cartoon
I don't know if it was a lot skinnier
yeah again that's one of those things
was like I don't know if I could see
like a Dwayne Johnson size dude playing
that character is the problem like I
feel like Luke Evans for translating
this into live-action is a great trick
like he looks great and he's got you
know his little flourishes when he's you
know like looking at himself in the
mirror and like he's good at playing
cartoony but all creating or - he's a
great singer yeah but I am singing I
think that is
yeah he's I was surprised I was that's
the thing as I was impressed by his book
yeah and I wasn't expecting to be and
this isn't a spoiler video so we're not
going to give anything away but they do
make some plot changes with his
character to make him a lot more
unlikable yeah which we were there for
an Andrea from movie source who who
didn't like that I like it though I did
too and necessary there were this live
filming me I think you can explain that
better yeah I just feel like if you're
gonna anytime you're hopping over from
one medium to another you know you're
hopping from animation to live-action
there's certain stuff that you're going
to factor out you know with animation
you know there's certain things your
mind will just naturally factor out with
animation you accept a more heightened
tone and a more tighten set of rule
that's fine but you know there are
certain things that when you translate
them to live-action just would look
funky or so carrier you know or which is
why making a beauty the beasts
live-action that families can all see is
kind of a tricky thing with Luke Evans
like making him yelling making those
changes like making them a little more
decisively unlikable is it helps us out
when we're jumping over here because
it's it just defines some of the things
he gets yeah you know because if you're
going to see a dude you know fault is
death well because one thing you pointed
out was how the beats in this movie
played by Dan Stephen so I thought did a
pretty good job yes I like the music
feels charming and everything I thought
he did a good job when you're watching a
cartoon you're more forgiving for
certain acts but when you're watching
like these two we've established is
really a human being like the movie
makes that very clear at the beginning
of the film with the beast you take from
animation to live-action when you watch
this movie because it's live-action
you're more aware like this is some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] the Beast is doing its
domestic violence nobody do it well I
think that's why it works
I think that's probably why it worked a
little better for me two seconds when we
finally got to see the Beast interact
with present-day characters for a while
he's pretty informant formidable oh yeah
he's got a terrible rage temper yeah
he's real mad he imprisoned it barely
dad and he's imprisoning that his dick
felt like his slave he takes out on base
and generally angry that was just so
quit and he'll like a thrashed up he's
domestically violent oh but this guy
that's why I think bringing it back to
Luke Evans making him worse is good for
the film because there's a lot you gotta
get forgiving on with the beef and the
film is a good job of allowing that to
happen
because it's a bigger ask in a
live-action movie yes to sympathize with
the beast and so it has to be a bigger
villainy yeah and that to balance and
it's harder worth to to make us like the
beast when you're watching him treat
humans a certain way well especially
nowadays yeah of this very end
and this is an updated version you know
at least hopefully to combat but I like
tuxes I like the touches they have with
Belle in the zone yes I loved having a
maid the mother a presence of the story
how she her mom wasn't around and she
doesn't know what happened I love how
they explored that so the cartoon
doesn't do that and I thought that added
a lot of dimension not just to the film
but especially to Emma Watson's
performance I felt I gave her a lot more
to work off of in terms of developing
her the characters seeing why she is the
way she is the touch of Kevin Kline
saying your mother was fearless that
made more sense for me why this girl
from this village would not would stand
up for what's right and not be afraid of
the Beast and everything because she's
honoring that was it because it seems
like Disney really is using their
platform right now it to be like you
know we're gonna remake one of our
beloved friends yeah movies will fuch go
go yeah
you know princesses and go you know very
very empowering little note overthrown
in you know which is hey do it one thing
about the beast though that I really
wish they just did the whole house of
castle everyone being CGI a fine that's
probably this it's like teacups and [ __ ]
well it actually does a the Lumiere I'll
grab yeah whatever the clock of the day
that yeah they look great they're an MCG
is really good at replicating [ __ ] I
already know is an object
yeah like but the beast while I get
there are certain moments where yada
needs to be CGI the amount of how he was
designed there was so many times where I
was thinking why didn't they try
practical maybe they did but I was
thinking it's you could have done
practical with this you you could have
you resent even money they have and what
we've seen from other films in general
and there is could have been practical
there are up some incredible and I mean
you could you could have you know done
assistance or something but there are
some incredible you know prosthetics and
mastery as they make now and end things
with animatronics and stuff like because
there's plenty of times were just the
beasts look so fake and like so CGI and
it would pull me out of filming I feel
like that's a big reason to why I didn't
feel like this film was sweeping me was
because I just didn't fully believe that
this was a real
all the time it just looks so fake in
some shots it's just way too CGI for me
yeah I don't know what it is but you
know it's like you get big gross in the
little details and you know there are
certain shots and bits where he does
look good
but it always like it for me I'm just
always reminded that oh yeah I'm looking
at pretty good CGI yeah isn't always
great yeah that's what I mean that like
it doesn't pull you in to the point
where you forget it's CGI I know that
part of this is like oh we're gonna fuse
the character with your perform a scene
you mocap this and I won't feel like you
did a good job through it but I feel
like he almost would have done a better
job
we were just some makeup you know yeah I
don't think I know is there yeah and it
would have made it better for us of the
eyes because when you're constantly
going back and forth between that's not
good CGI - oh that's pretty good CGI
your your thoughts are going that's good
CGI but you're not pulled into it like I
don't like how dawn of the Planet of the
Apes pulled me into the point where I
was like I'm forgetting I'm watching TGI
characters one also in the scenes show
you focus on that stuff more and that's
probably the easiest thing to latch on
to because there are moments where I
wasn't thinking about it and I was just
dazzled by their relationship unfolding
you know the network hampered by me
going you know that's sure big upper
buddy because on the relationship you
when they start to get along and they
start to really bond yeah that was
really good I bought it I believed it
yeah and it and it was like I think it's
a challenge on Emma Watson's part but I
felt the dimensions and the little later
the attitude character made it a lot
easier for me to grasp that by the end
of this movie she could fall in love
with this guy yeah yeah they actually
connect and it gives a guy like me hope
hope is what I wanted Josh GAD is Lefou
Josh GAD I like the touch of physically
gay stuff in this old Robbie
they added black people and gay people
to this movie what is good food again
Disney is busy
in a burst the biggest tower in all the
land and they're smart enough snow we
got appeal to everybody yeah and I'd
also like this a good thing to do
morally speaking and you know with a
movie like this where it's all about
height in production oh yeah throw every
kind of person in there where's our
friends you did a fantasy friend you
know this is Rancho del British accent
from mere the candle has the only French
accent but you know if you're doing I
think if you're doing a fantasy it
actually helps the story because if you
really do it at least nowadays you
really do it like historically accurate
you're gonna have a bunch of people just
wondering about that yeah why are we
focusing on this one it looks like your
life is a little strange out here Josh
GAD I liked him I did he's not a bad
singer the thing though is he's the only
one who felt that's like weird I really
enjoyed him and he definitely made me
laugh but he's you know when I felt all
very modern everyone else felt like they
were in that time period I felt like
this dude was a modern-day dear to me
yeah dad
dude I don't really know Josh yeah to
work with the splitters all being it was
like gee he sees what's funny about him
being gay Coquina
yes yeah he has all these little
mannerisms that are very you know very
now very sassy and stuff like that
either they are funny he's I think this
movie does have sort of a their few
people who are on different levels of
cartoony and he was a little bigger yeah
then I was I guess maybe hoping for but
I still liked him I still enjoyed his
songs and stuff in his little bits of
performance but yeah he is a I always
felt like he was just hanging out in the
cottage exactly right a guy in the play
still hanging out when we're doing the
scene but I think him and Luke Evans
play off each other really well
Yallah Yallah and that was the most
important aspect to that character I
think was the buddy for Luke Evans oh
yeah they have to you can't have them
not get along somehow you know and as
far as people in the castle Emma
Thompson Emma Thompson at all mrs. Potts
right Ian McKellen as Cogsworth and Eva
McGregor Lumiere I thought were great
especially Eva McGregor III's Lumiere
performing a little wonderful I didn't
know was you a McGregor I was like with
the French actor they'd hire the next a
French actor is gonna think of right now
well it didn't occur because it is like
a tone down French accent a little bit
like you know says the kids can still
hear it but yeah I mean like I'd
forgotten I think I heard he was cast
now is I was like I don't I don't I
didn't think of it but Wow yeah and I
was pleasantly surprised you know the
great Jay is super charming sexy ken is
awesome yeah dancing like there's
perfect they should have the whole like
all the objects in the house I thought
were terrific oh yeah everybody
personality person they're animated
really great you know the way that they
move you know because there are more
details now you can see more you know
gears you know and bits and pieces and
those things all a that CG looks great
like the the Wardrobe like whatever that
thing I talks you like her curtains blow
in there I mean like that little of that
I could see them doing like bringing
that to life at Disneyland or something
unless that was actually real light
which who knows maybe that could have
been you know or at least the sister
would see if you have the time it was
real but yeah the whole house staff and
the voices are great like you understand
why they got everybody they got I
thought and the animation is great in
there I know some people have complained
about them and there are some really
beautiful sequences you know like be our
guest is like trippy in there
psychedelic and becomes a full-on like
number now so that breaks the the bounds
of you know just narrative reality and
like that stuff I thought was really
cool and that was one partly the 3d
sorry to get did they let her eat I
don't think they did I got the running
joke is like she's always about to eat
something and they're like who is a
production but yeah and like that's
another thing that's pretty darn
impressive about this movie it's just
the metal bit of the production value
you know like the sets and the the
locations and the costumes but also the
amount of people and choreography and
stuff like they put a ton of work into
this movie and a lot of it does pay off
I thought like I know you don't like
musicals
I do but I've come to more appreciate
just the artistry of seeing people you
know do musical numbers like this and
see how people shoot them and I thought
everything for those for me came
together top notch I was like yeah
you're throwing down these song and
dance musical numbers and they're pretty
dazzling but you know they're people who
know more about that [ __ ] lighting so
that's fair that's fair
most of the editions they add is for the
most part of the cartoon photos Bart is
exactly the cartoon
there's a few things they added that I
have covered some of them that I don't
like and do like they added a musical
number that I thought danced even sing
wonderfully well but I didn't like this
scene though it's when after if you guys
seen the cartoon minor spoiler when
Belle goes leave the castle to go help
her father out dance Stevens in this one
instead of a roar he breaks into a song
about why he's depressed and Belle's
leaving I'm going to be alone so too
much mostly at that's too sensitive for
the Beast right yeah I don't know I just
did I thought I thought like all beasts
went away at that point and but I kept
okay though because totally it's okay I
just didn't like it in the movie that's
fair I mean I now exactly I now remember
exactly which scene you're talking about
because at first I was like where did
that sit at least from this standpoint
like I would have to go back and
re-watch it and see if it you know
affects my enjoyment of that chunk of
the movie but I remember thinking it I
do like that he gets a song at that
moment cuz I'm the three crucial moment
I like the way they shot it a lot that
that weird thing where he's like walking
through the castle and they're showing
like her through our windows and they're
like he's climbing taller a tower into
this big lonely desolate empty place
watching the one little ray of sunshine
leave because it has to that was a well
conceived sequence at least well I just
think in the animated movie and like
this movie is doing the animated movie I
think for the most part it is just being
the animated movie how he responds them
the moment they leave him with is really
effective in the animated movie in the
movie was doing what the animated movie
had done but instead of a roar and anger
or whatever I just I don't know I just
it seemed a little out of character for
me in that moment
for imp to just fully sink into that or
if one could justify that it shows that
he's really changed he's become no more
sensitive man it's tough to do I don't
think is that it's a bad choice per se
but I'm also affected that's my point
that's fair I mean lei it's also been a
very long time since I saw the original
movie like I know I saw it a bunch of
times growing up I have a reasonable
working knowledge of it you know I'm not
sitting here like ah you know this how
this harks back to the original you know
so if I wasn't that going to rewatch
that some of these moments might come
down in magic value for me which is
which is just disclosure well know when
I was watching the movie I was I didn't
immediately think why are they adding
this this house this time I'm like I'm
not really liking this thing and then I
went wait a minute is this even in the
original movie I remember thinking that
halfway through going I don't even think
this was in the original movie I don't
know just the way that whole scene was
done with I mean it's shot cool there's
things to appreciate about it his
singing is really good I don't know if I
thought it was song yeah that was more
diverse I say that was the part I wasn't
sure if I actually liked the song and
then then the thing too about these
kinds of movies is sometimes it's hard
to decipher the lyrics when you've got
other [ __ ] around you know and it's a
feeder and it's one you know I've heard
this song before you can't fill in blank
so yeah that's the one part of that
scene ie I made note of and I still
don't know is it my mistake didn't Josh
grobin like write that song I think so
and I don't always love it music but I
thought it was already heartbreaking and
when when the Beast had to let Belle go
and it was already sad they all given up
and it's like what's really milked as
always lost mode we have another song no
we don't need a song right now yeah I
might have just been this song cuz I was
thinking that too
because I agree a lot of what you're
saying like it's not a bad choice it's
cool that he gets his own number as cool
as he added that too it was just the way
the song was right and care for it yeah
oh dude wait shut up kevin kline bro Oh
Kevin Carnac really keep the Adamic line
was wicked and I can't wait because I
got my first big laugh from Kevin going
and I can't wait for all the Maurice was
raving memes to come out of this
yeah like it's gonna happen I just know
it is rating system time I would say
this movie is really good oh really
I feel like I felt like I liked it more
than you guys come out of the movie
theater like Anaya and I would go with
pretty good thanks pretty good like idea
is like an enthusiastic pretty good you
know like this my rating system is all
about my tone of voice feeling pretty
good
it's intermittently magical and then you
know when you're pulled out of it you're
still at least like there's still a lot
of really great stuff here through its
magical sometimes I cried once it's just
as I D cry it doesn't come all together
right well you can subscribe the real
rejects John just to go to the
description box and look at all this you
know what to do you've been here before
goodbye